Taylor Lorenz posted a few days before
New Year's that it was like Loki the
greatest of all time to stay home on New
Year's because we're also exhausted then
posted on New Year's how awful it was
for people to be posting these party
selfies when ERS are being overloaded
and right there you could see exactly
what's going on with this with this
Taylor Lorenz this Tate I feel I felt so
bad for her because you know you know on
New Year's
I'm with my girlfriend I'm with Luke
Luke's you know we got a bunch of uh my
brothers there
and we're standing there in Times Square
at a party and the ball drop happens and
I get to kiss my girlfriend we're
surrounded by people with free food and
drinks and we're all laughing and like
he's amazing and then I see her tweets
and she's like it's good to be home
alone with no friends I can't believe
people are posting videos and I was like
damn
I feel so bad for her I did kind of feel
bad too is she lashing out this way
because she's just lonely and desperate
that's what I would think yes